i think my all-time favorite impression
of yours was jimmy stewart
and i used to think that's an impression
that everyone knows because no matter
how many years go by people still watch
it's a wonderful life he's
it's the you know that was kind of the
first impression i ever
wanted to learn you know and we didn't
have tape recorders then
basically so i was with my friends in a
volkswagen bug in
in 1975 and they were stoned and it's
it started to hit me i started to do it
and i started to be able to talk like
him you know
and this is true story they went into a
jack-in-the-box and we're in there and
then i went through the drive-through
and they said they said i want to take
an order this true story and i said yeah
yeah i'd like a jumbo jack with cheese
and the guy thought it was jimmy stewart
or pretended to say hey
is this jimmy stewart after a bit more
of that so that became a thing and uh
when i was on deep dive with you on your
podcast yeah
we did do you guys know jimmy stewart is
from it's a wonderful life yeah
you get a thing where he's he's in the
car
he's in a he's sitting in a car with uh
i guess katherine hepburn
yeah and uh they're doing an illicit
kind of oral
sexual activity sure and jimmy stewart
like i don't like things that are
overtly sexual but just him in that
situation with his vernacular would be
like yeah
well take your time
[Laughter]
no reason to rush it
well just just look at it for a bit yeah
now now look away
we'll flip in the other direction now
look back at it and act
so it surprised goes on and on was
crying
and then i was calling my brothers and
doing it for them on the phone
not you know i couldn't do that but
doing the same thing yeah
just i just loved it it was just the
voice is so good and it makes me believe
that that's happening
that was always like when i was working
at clubs in the early days and just
hells angels and drunk people and
bombing like crazy
jimmy stewart as a waiter never didn't
save my act
like i'd be just tanking jimmy stewart
as a waiter
was always the go-to like yeah well can
i take your order
well what do you mean you don't know the
specials i told them to you ten minutes
ago
what do you want me to stand here like a
trained monkey and tell them to
you again or what what'd you say well
[ __ ] you
i'm never fat never fail